people talk about population collapse
overall globally what is your view of
global population so assuming that
globalization continues from its height
onward we were already in the process of
revising down our estimates so it used
to be 15 years ago that we thought by
2050 we were going to have 11 to 12
billion people that number is now under
10 and as the data continues to get
upgraded we'll probably Peak at just
below nine and then start falling back
gently looking at the ways in which
population collapse and the reduction of
that could be tied in with automation is
there any technological savior that can
come through and assist us with the
problems that we're facing at the moment
absolutely so pros and cons there are a
lot of Technologies with automation Ai
and Robotics that look really good but
it also requires massive economies of
scale the most expensive thing a country
can do isn't industrialized it's to
automate it does use different labor and
less labor but it's not clear to me that
it really moves the needle in a huge way